welcome
to the press conference following the
video conference of the president of the
european
council we are joined remotely by the
president of the european commission
and we'll organize a q a session
following
uh the president's speech first but
first let me point out that we will
publish
the conclusions of the president of the
european council on our website shortly
there's translation in french english
and german
and now i turn to the president thank
you
good afternoon everyone today we met by
video conference to discuss
the increasingly concerning situation
in belarus and which press one clear
message
the european union stands in solidarity
with the people of belarus and
we don't accept impunity
on august 9th belarus held elections
these elections were neither free nor
fair and did not meet international
standards
we don't recognize the results presented
by the belarus authorities the people of
belarus deserve
better the deserve the democratic right
to choose their leaders
and shape their future in the wake of
these elections
belarusians have taken to the streets
with smart
protests and strikes from ordinary
families
to students and factory workers the
violence
against these peaceful protesters was
shocking and unacceptable
we condemn this brutality and expect
a full and transparent investigation
any violence must be avoided this
includes
any repression and violence against
those seeking to engage in
national dialogue efforts strong civil
society
and independent media are key elements
civil society and opposition actors
engaged in discussions of political
transition
must be protected from arbitrary arrests
and violence the protests
in belarus are not about geopolitics
this is in the first place a national
crisis
this is about the right of the people to
freely elect their leadership
wisdom we stand firmly behind the right
of belarusian people
to determine their own fate and
the eu will impose shortly sanctions
on a substantial number of individuals
responsible for violence
repression and election throat
we call on the belarusian authorities to
find a peaceful way out of the crisis
by ending by ending the violence
distillating tensions
and launching an inclusive national
dialogue
all parties including third states
should support such a process we will
continue to follow the situation closely
and stand ready to contribute to efforts
to peacefully end the crisis the eu
fully supports osce proposals for
dialogue in belarus
and is ready to provide assistance
to further them to conclude
i would like to address the people of
belarus directly
we stand by your side in your desire to
exercise your fundamental
democratic rights and in your desire for
a peaceful
democratic and prosperous future
we had also the occasion to raise the
situation
in the eastern mediterranean and
this question and relations with turkey
were raised by different member states
we expressed our full solidarity with
greece and cell priests
and we called and reaffirmed our
previous conclusions
on the illegal drilling activities
we agreed to revert on to those issues
during our meeting in september all
options will be on the table
finally we raised
the event in mali the events in mali are
of deep concern
and can have a destabilizing impact on
the entire region
and on the fight against terrorism
thank you mr president we will now turn
to the president of the european
commission
madam president thank you
but uh thank you shao
the people of belarus want change
and they want it now and
we are impressed by the courage
of the people of belarus for exactly 10
days
since the presidential election took
place
the people of belarus have taken to the
streets
in unprecedented numbers
they demand the release of all
unlawfully detained
prisoners the prosecution of those
responsible for police brutality
they want freedom of speech and assembly
and they want democracy and new
presidential elections
as these elections were neither fair
nor free today
we gave them three clear messages
firstly we stand by the people of
belarus
who want fundamental freedoms and
democracy
secondly we will sanction
all those responsible for violence
repression
and falsification of the results of the
election
the people of belarus took peacefully
to the streets and the authorities
answered
with violence and this cannot be
accepted
and thirdly we are ready to accompany
peaceful democratic transition of power
in belarus
firstly on the support we already
provide a lot of support
to belarus through the eastern
partnership
but now it is more important than ever
to be there for the belarus people
and to reprogram money away from the
authorities
and towards civil society and vulnerable
groups
the european commission will mobilize
now
an additional 53 million euros
to support the belarusian people in
these challenging times
two million euro to assist the victims
of
repression and unacceptable state
violence
one million euro to support civil
society
and independent media
and 50 million euros of corona virus
support for the health sector for
example hospitals
or the procurement of medical equipment
but also for small and medium
enterprises
of vulnerable groups of social services
but as we increase our support to the
people of belarus
we must be firm with those that rigged
the elections
and are repressing brutally
demonstrators
so secondly there was unanimous
support for the eu
to be working on sanctions against those
responsible for what is taking place
targeted sanctions on specific persons
without hurting the people of balos
the commission stands ready to support
and the list of people submitted to
sanctions
should be adopted as soon as possible
and thirdly we stand ready to engage in
all possible ways to accompany
peaceful democratic transition of power
in belarus we support the opening of
dialogue between
authorities and the opposition
and there was strong support for role of
the osce
the osce might be seeking ways to
facilitate dialogue in belarus
belarus is member of the osce
it's not so much a mediation but on
opening
communication channels within belarus
finally the demonstrations in belarus
are not against any neighboring country
or entity the demonstrations in belarus
are for the rights of the people of
belarus
this is about the belarusian people and
their legitimate
right to determine the future path
of their country the european union
stands at the side
of the belarusian people violence
has to stop only an inclusive
dialogue will find solutions
the future of belarus must be decided
by the belarusian people in belarus it
must grow from within
thank you thank you madam president
for your message and we'll turn to the q
a session now
we have a lot of people tuning in please
let me state on beforehand could you
please
um state clearly whom you want to
address your question to so that it
makes easier to switch from one side to
the other
we'll start with john chalmers from
reuters
john you have the floor
can you hear us john yes hello yes can
you hear me
yes please yes hi and this is a
question for the uh the president of the
european council
in the recent hours while the uh eu
leaders were meeting uh president shenko
ordered the police
to put down protests in minsk and this
signals an escalation of the situation
there did you take this into account
during your conversations
and what is your response to the latest
developments
our message is very clear stop the
violence
and we don't accept the impunity we
don't tolerate the impunity and that's
why we took this a very
important decision it's our intention to
decide
sanctions targeted extensions in order
to target
the individual's authorities involved
in the process of violence or in the
falsification of the elections
and we will continue in the next hours
also in the next days
to follow closely the situation we don't
accept the violence and the fact that we
took this decision to
have this meeting today with a very
strong and
united message uh it sends
to the authorities in belarus a very
clear
message from the european union
thank you next question for carolina
meter basil
carolina thank you very much
i'm hearing is it just
could you raise the volume a bit yes
that's
yes i'll try
my question goes to to which one of you
wants to answer actually because you
have
repeated both of you have said that you
want to to work on sanctions on those
responsible
and i was wondering whether you have
talked about whether mr lukashenko
himself should be included on this list
and also i'm interested on the time
frame
how soon you think you will be able to
to talk about
the content of the list and to agree and
to agree on this list thank you very
much
there is there is uh there is a process
there is a legal process at the european
level
uh we had today the political
distribution and we sent a very clear
uh signal about uh our decision to
implement sanctions but of course it
will be
the responsibility at the european
levels
of the different committees involved in
the process
to formally take the decision and
repeat we will shortly impose
sanctions against a substantial number
of individuals responsible for violence
and the question about president lucas
shinto will be
deliberated in the framework of this
process
maybe you would like to add
yes thank you it is exactly as the
president of the council said
the commission stands ready to support
because
it is a very detailed process with a lot
of scrutiny
but the ministers for foreign affairs
now the european council were very clear
and we will work hard to be ready as
soon as possible with a list
of specific persons targeted for
sanctions another question now
for jennifer ranking the guardian
jennifer
are you there uh yes i'm there
you see me yes if you switch on your
camera makes it nicer for us
okay okay just bear with me
i my camera's switched on you can see me
okay
thank you very much this is a question
to
president michelle i'm sorry for the
echo but i hope it's clear
and president michelle you spoke to
president putin
yesterday can you say whether you see
the russian government as an ally or as
a destabilizing force
in resolving the situation in belarus
and what is it exactly that you would
like
the the russian government to be doing
thank you
we sent a very clear a very clear
message we think that
the future of belarus has to be decided
by the people
in belarus not in brussels not in moscow
and we think
there is a national crisis and we would
like to enter
all the positive efforts in order to
make
a national inclusive dialogue possible
and we had the occasion we spent putin
to to distress
the situation in belarus and i think
it's important from
both sides in moscow in brussels that we
that you are convinced that we need to
support
all the positive efforts in order to
find a peaceful solution
in order to guarantee a democratic
process in belarus
and i repeat that for us for the
european union it's very clear
that the people in belarus they have the
fundamental right
to elect freely their leadership
next question is for rickard josiak i
hope i pronounce your name correctly
ricard can you hear us absolutely i can
can you hear me
yes and very good pronunciation by the
way buttons thank you
uh following up from jennifer rankin's
question
to mr michelle did you get any
references from mr putin
today that russia will not interfere in
belarus military or otherwise
and for mr vondelay mrs von the lion um
since you don't see the elections as
free and fair
are you demanding a re-run of these
elections
and uh yeah let's go for those two
the talks yesterday uh with uh with
vladimir putin it was the occasion for
me
to express a very strong european
conviction
we are convinced indeed that it's
important to give the possibility
in belarus through a national dialogue
to find a solution
and indeed i repeat that we want to
avoid
external negative interferences and yet
the occasion we sir
when you put into a very clear and very
friendly exchange of views
and change of opinions about the current
situation
and probably you have observed uh
the last hours uh some statements made
by the kremlin
uh in in the direction that they don't
intend in those current circumstances
uh to intervene in belarus at the
military level
turning to the president of the european
commission
madam president yes
thank you baron it is the belarusian
people
who are demanding a re-run of
truly free and fair elections and i want
to be very clear
and this is is the attitude
we have that we support the belarusian
people
in them choosing the path they
want to have they want to go down
so it's their decision on where they
want to
um lead their country to too
but we support them but we have the
respect
that the belarusian people themselves
are free to decide and
to determine how they want to shape
their country
and how they see the future of belarus
now we're going to take two more
questions uh first of all jakobo
barigatsi from politico jacopo can you
hear us
is can you hear me yes please hey i
have uh thank you thank you byron i have
a couple of questions for
president michelle first of all during
your contacts you reach out also
to our transatlantic partners uh to
coordinate any kind of
effort and secondly uh what do you think
that uh we'll avoid uh a repetition of
the situation that we had
in ukraine uh with the russian
annexation of
crimea and so on uh whether we have
whether the you has
learned from uh what happened there
uh to avoid repetition of these things
european
[Music]
situation
[Music]
last question now for athanasios
athanasius can you hear us
please turn on your microphone
athanasios
i think that's fine now it's it's
working thanks for the question
um could we this question is for both
if i may could we see today's decision a
discussion as a prequel
to the discussion that will follow up on
turkey
uh in the next couple of weeks and in
the end of september and i specifically
refer to the issue of sanctions
since at least two member states feel
right now and i think that was expressed
in the
uh in the teleconference as well that uh
the imminence of the situation of
belarus
took let's say uh
came to the forefront while the other
pressing these two towers two member
states
became you know was lowered in
intensity in the last couple of
weeks so should we expect the
same sense of urgency in the issue of
sanctions
when you will discuss the issue of
turkey that's
what some of yours want to want to know
thanks
um
foreign madam president
maybe you would like to ask a couple of
words
yes um
thank you there's little to us
and of course these are two different
situations
because we have a long history
with turkey of opportunities
cooperation but also conflicts and
uh it is very clear that uh the
relationship with turkey
will be subject not only with the
foreign ministers of
the ministers of foreign affairs but
also uh
on the table of the european council and
as the president of the european
council said all options will be on the
table
for us is first and foremost important
important the willingness on all sides
to engage in a problem solving dialogue
this is the most important there are
problems out there there are conflicts
out there
and they should be solved together thank
you madam president and mr president
please to all of you keep an eye out to
our council website
this afternoon where we will publish the
conclusions of the president of the
european council
following the video conference thanks
again and see you
in september
[Music]
you